good afternoon everybody I have the
challenge of going straight after lunch
but I hopefully I'm up to the challenge
first I just want to thank Mary and Yale
for inviting me here today it's just a
real pleasure and it's it's fun to sort
of partake of the obvious joy and and
devotion to the program and to the
profession I think certainly that we all
share and I'm going to talk about some
research I did for my dissertation for
the dr ph and how this came about was
the first time i went to the island
which was for a PA e a board of
directors meeting initially and then we
had our full meeting i was at that time
working on some international things and
it just occurred to me that this was
part of the united states and it was
there were no pas there and here we were
sub-saharan Africa all kinds of other
places they developed PA analogs and yet
there were none on the island before i
start i do want to do a linguistic note
which is I can't say Puerto Rico but i'm
going to say Puerto Rico because
shockingly when I did all my interviews
I discovered a lot of people on the
island pronounce it puerto rico as well
so i just so you know i can say it
properly and an interesting sidelight of
history after the spanish-american war
in 1898 when Puerto Rico became part of
the u.s. one of the things that was
mandated by the US government was to
print to spell it p 0 RT 0 instead of
Puerto and which is interesting since
that word exists in Portuguese but not
in Spanish the other thing that's always
controversial is whether it's a
territory or a colony or a free
associated state and I'll just recognize
that there are a number of viewpoints on
that and that's not really any direct
part of my conversation so as I've
alluded to Puerto Rico is the last large
jurisdiction in the u.s. that does not
have pas it is an island 100
miles this way by 35 miles this way and
very important as we talk about access
to care is to look at this very large
mountain range that bisects the island
so my research question was what are the
barriers and potential facilitators to
enabling legislation for pas in Puerto
Rico now and many of you are familiar
with this already so forgive me for
boring you but a qualitative approach
means that we're looking for an in-depth
understanding but not generalizability
and what this means is rather than a
random sample from which we can
generalize we have a purposeful sample
where we try to very carefully select
our subjects for in this case for
interview and in order to gain a deep
understanding of the answers to the
question and in order to do that I look
for a wide representation of key context
in Puerto Rico including all four of the
medical schools physicians in primary
care and specialties not just physicians
but pas and decision-makers and
administrators so legislators folks in
the government and people in the health
insurance industry i did 25
semi-structured interviews meaning i had
a list of questions but i could follow
up somewhat extemporaneously on those
based on answers and the majority of the
interviews were conducted in Puerto Rico
in January 2008 since I am a member of
the Duke faculty and was also a graduate
student at UNC I had the unique
wonderful experience of having to go
through to irvs which had very different
approaches I sit on that I'm a member of
the Duke IRB so I was familiar with that
and they're they're not so familiar with
qualitative researcher at research at do
because you might imagine so they
thought everything I did was just fine
UNC Chapel Hill had found a number of
gaps in my approach but it was what
you're supposed to do in school is learn
and I definitely did from that
experience
interviews were conducted in both
English and Spanish based on either
English or Spanish I guess doing both
would be Spanglish but we did either
language based on the preference of the
interview subject I then transcribed all
of the interviews myself which resulted
in a dissertation related injury which
was a tendon itís in my right ankle as a
result of going back and back and back
and listening to make sure I'd
understood what had been said now one of
the members of my my dissertation
committee Otilio de ramos who is a true
gentleman and scholar physician
assistant who's originally from Puerto
Rico he sat down and listened to all of
them with me to make sure I had it right
and he caught a few interesting things
at one point a physician I said do you
think there's a need for pas in Puerto
Rico and he said I think they're asking
for them is how I had captured it
pedindo but I missed he sort of mumbled
after that a grito screaming for them so
OT leo's help was very very necessary to
catch her capture really the true sense
and i coated these interviews based on
themes using the software atlas TI they
interview questions and of course my
dissertation is available for your
pleasure reading through ProQuest and of
course all the appendices and contain
actual questions both in English and
Spanish and so forth but the aim was to
find out about what they knew about pas
what attitudes were what in particular
they believed about access to care as it
would then translate toward need and
what they thought about the adequacy of
the physician supply on island I was
very interested in learning and stress
about the structure and politics of
organized medicine and specific barriers
and then what strategies we might evolve
to try and achieve enabling legislation
the major perspectives broke down is one
might predict into those were pro and
those work on the antagonists just
simply i called them an antagonists and
proponents antagonist said really that
pas weren't needed you know obviously go
into some more depth about their sort of
their discourse around that proponents
felt that pas were not only needed they
were needed urgently or a good eat
though and they also these two groups
displayed really fundamental differences
in their beliefs about access to care
and whether it was good or not so the
themes that I then coated were
antagonists proponent and then cross
cutting things that I heard from both
groups the antagonist themes really said
that there were plenty of physicians on
the island supply was physician is
sufficient they have for medical schools
and that pas were just simply not needed
and certainly if one looks at the number
they're absolutely right the number per
hundred thousand of physicians is pretty
much the same as it is on in mainland us
they said it's it's a small island that
was something I heard a lot that
geographic access was not an issue
because you were always just really
close to health care and that really
patients would not accept pas that was
just not something that was going to
work culturally and furthermore that pas
would experience a really negative
practice environment it just wouldn't be
a good place for us and we should really
you know we were best advised to direct
our efforts out elsewhere I have to stop
for just a minute and say even among
those most ardently opposed universally
all of the folks that I spoke with were
gracious kind I think generous in
allowing me their time and one of the
challenges when you're sort of an you
know part of the experiment is to
maintain that distance and not and not
engage in you know personal feelings
about the
that you know I know we all love so much
and I've got a chapter about that in the
in the dissertation of course just about
trying to maintain distance now the
proponent themes were that it's fine to
say it's a small island but there are a
lot of transportation barriers that even
if it's it looks close as the crow flies
it could be extremely difficult they
talked about waiting for care
particularly and this is important for
my future my later recommendations
particularly with respect to medical and
surgical subspecialties there was a long
wait for care and people would go to
clinics for primary care without an
appointment system and wait to be seen
and then something came up which is the
henna listas or the generalist
physicians and I think it was good that
Spanish was not one of my first
languages and so I had to be really
careful about making sure I understood
what people were telling me so I didn't
take base value for words if I wasn't
really a hunter isn't clear so when they
talked about that at least does I said
well tell me what that means well it
turns out what that means is these are
physicians who graduated from caribbean
medical schools who do not speak english
who cannot do the USMLE who then come to
Puerto Rico to practice and take a local
board which is given in Spanish and then
they do a one-year internship which is
usually not a standardized internship
and then they comprise most of the
primary care and urgent care on the
island that physicians another theme was
physician flight from the island that
those physicians who were trained at the
University of Puerto Rico Medical Center
on for example half of them left to go
to the US after they've got to the US
mainland Puerto Rico's part of the u.s.
I don't want to make mistakes like that
too in order to practice because they
would make such better income and have
so much so many fewer hassles in terms
of support and that they have been
creating PA like rolls the theme i
called it was below the radar that was
my code below
radar that they were taking orderlies
and EMTs and this is sound familiar it
was sort of the Buddy Treadwell story
all over again where they were teaching
people to do things and having them do
things but not calling them PA it was
just below the radar and this turned out
to be true in a lot of subspecialties
the cross-cutting things that both
proponents and antagonists talked about
were opposition not just from organized
medicine but from nursing and it's
important to note that there is one
nurse practitioner at least at the time
there was one nurse practitioner program
on the island but NPS do not have
enabling legislation either and the
target that they're seeking is primary
care again important as I get to my
recommendations there were increasing
health care costs an interesting fact is
that the percentage of uninsured on the
island is about 8% about half of the
mainland us which is about 15 but in the
same way that doctors per square inch
does not translate to access to care
having a card does not necessarily
translate to access to care this was
something called a lottery for tomorrow
which was put through by a governor who
was actually a surgeon he's a physician
and this happened at the height of that
heady time in 1993 when we thought we
would have health care reform and Puerto
Rico actually put through a version of
the clinton plan but despite that Puerto
Rico is the highest percent of their
gross product spent on health care even
more than the mainland us about eighteen
percent so they were really facing that
in the face of the lowest per capita
income about half of that of Mississippi
another theme that I termed was
something I turned disorganized medicine
that organized medicine was broken into
two camps one were the sort of
university-trained University of Puerto
Rico boarded
physicians including family physicians
and then the other group of henna
released us who had largely taken
control of of organized medicine on the
island in a really fascinating story
that we don't have time for but it
really created a different political
milieu within within organized medicine
and they were currently told me that was
very disorganized in that there were
different camps and even the proponents
had a very poor understanding of PAS
they would say things like well they can
see patients but they can't prescribe
sort of like Harvey sd's talked about it
back in the 60s you know they can they
can take histories and help the doctor
but they they really can't treat so some
of the context really got down to how
one defines access and again if you just
look at insurance number of physicians
and so forth you might assume a certain
picture but acceptability transportation
issues these sort of social context
issues that create problems were really
huge barriers to access and that
politics is absolutely one of the
favorite sports in Puerto Rico it is I I
spent some time in Texas and I was I was
one of those people that the lobbied for
for for PA enabling legislation in Texas
and I thought that was entertaining but
Puerto Rico is just people talk about
politics you know it's just it's it's a
conversation in a way that we just
really aren't familiar with here in the
in the majority culture and a lot of
scandals a lot of things going on during
the time I was there the Medical Board
had been alleged to be selling passing
scores on the local board there was you
know allegations of corruption and the
governor's office and so forth so it's
it's always something political they're
very much hierarchy as I've alluded to
of social organization of medical
just with board-certified physicians
versus Senate release does and that
physician occupational prestige is still
an extremely important social factor and
in fact physicians do enjoy I think more
prestige and respect than perhaps is
true now in this day here in this
country and universally the henna
release does were said to be predicted
to oppose I think tooth and nail would
be the phrase the introduction of pas
and the one large study that has been
done of physician attitudes towards
piezo nurse practitioners back in 81
Ferraro and Sutherland it was a large
sample based on interviews and what they
found was the higher up in the hierarchy
you are of medicine more accepting you
are of pas lower in the hierarchy the
more threatened and resistant you are to
to pas and nurse practitioners and so I
think that that's some research I'd like
to see us do and perhaps get occasion to
try and do that to look at physician
attitudes in that same kind of way again
in 2011 the discourse very interesting i
briefly pursued a doctorate in sociology
and one of the reasons I desisted was
that it was very quantitative and as one
of my professors said you would be the
only cultural sociologist who's ever
graduated from this from Duke but I did
take some anthropology courses including
analysis of discourse and there are just
a lot of really interesting tidbits
within the interviews such as they use
future rather than conditional verbs so
they say well you will have this problem
and you will find rather than you would
and that spoke volumes to me because I
believe that back here if not up in the
frontal lobes the people all the people
i spoke to saw it is inevitable but
needed to continue that discourse
so it was you will rather than you would
and I also found the work of Hirshman
very interesting he talks about the
rhetoric in the rhetoric of reaction he
talks how people reject ideas that are
regarded as radical or disruptive
innovation and so forth and so he has a
whole sort of progression of that of
that rhetoric and one of them is
jeopardy you know and that would be in
this case okay it's going to be really
dangerous to have pas the quality of
care is going to be really bad and
impatience a patient safety patients
need to be kept safe so and we've all
who are old enough to have been through
that have heard that to varying degrees
depending on how early we got into the
profession and I didn't hear that I
really didn't hear danger not safe not
quality it was the the later argument of
futility you don't want to do it because
there's really no point it's not good at
your physicians or having trouble your
life is just going to be miserable to
patients won't accept you you know it's
it's futile so that to me was was very
interesting there other interesting
aspects of the discourse but in the
interest of time I'll just highlight
those two that I think are very
important my recommendations go to you
know what what Patrick spoke about what
Patrick and really everyone talked about
this morning which is the work is not
done we need to continue to work to
advocate and we have to be effective in
our advocacy and in the case of Puerto
Rico I think it needs to you have to be
really careful because there is so much
political division to be able to hire a
lobbyist who's a bit of you know
Switzerland and you know maybe has some
sort of status that allows people in the
different parties to listen to that
person I thought it was going to be
really important contrary to what I
thought before I did the research to
avoid primary care and the reason is
that was just going to get us into what
Andrew Abbott
professions sociologists it calls
jurisdictional struggles and you know
this this harkens back to the story
about pas and how we were formed by
physicians and didn't rest a piece of
turf or a piece of jurisdiction but
rather receded that jurisdiction because
the physicians could not cover the
entire jurisdiction so I think it would
be important for us to avoid
jurisdictional struggles that would be
inevitable with the henna releases and
with nurse practitioners and for that
reason I suggested that pilot PS be
piloted in the medical and surgical
specialties at the University of Puerto
Rico Medical Center which would allow
just a law that would be limited to that
place and hopefully not threatening to
others and would it would be sort of
like a Yale or you know Duke starting a
program like that which I think has a
lot to do with our acceptance as a
profession that you know if flagship
institutions took on this sort of
interesting new idea that you know
perhaps it would be more accepted and I
think it will be critical as I think it
is inevitable I don't know what the
timeline is but that we prospectively
evaluate really critical indicators of
quality acceptance access to care and so
forth and cost I'd like to acknowledge
and thank funding i received from
britain dorn from the PA foundation and
also from the josiah Charles Trent
Memorial Foundation at Duke and this is
the Legislative Building in San Juan
honestly I think one of the most
beautiful state capitals in the US if
you're in San Juan you really should go
in and and look at some of the beautiful
paintings on the ceilings you know this
rotunda for example just a beautiful
architecture in a beautiful building
with a lot of really proud and beautiful
history so in my time I think is
probably up but should I take questions
yes
interviewing Puerto Rican patients in
the mainland I didn't formally do that
obviously for scope and trying to get
your dissertation done informally I I
did talk to a lot of folks who talk to
me some of my interview subjects but I
had a few interview subjects that were
in the US and they spoke about you know
their family's struggles and and so
forth but you know it's there's the same
number of Puerto Ricans in the mainland
us there are on the island so there's a
very large population largely here on
the East Coast so that that could be
very interesting anything else yes well
I i completed study in 2008 the this was
a leadership doctorate in public health
in health policy and management from unc
chapel hill and i was in the first
cohort of this program and they said
that the goal of the program was 244 the
dissertations to make a difference in a
chief change and I I can't say that
that's happened but I can't say that now
that this is published an out there i do
get contacts contacted by I've been
contacted by several legislators I know
there's enabling legislation pending now
it has a number of problems that I think
go back to that thing about not really
understanding pas and it proposes a very
limited role but i think that the PA
world here in the mainland and folks who
are interested has really been energized
I don't claim because of my efforts but
just because this is really coming to
the forest is the last the last place in
America and there's a new there's a
satellite program of Chatham University
in I think pulse is it poncy yeah I am
on me and you were going to comment
go ahead having right now oh I'm sorry
this is about the fourth iteration I
think or third of bills that have been
passed or put forth this particular one
reminds me of what happened in Florida
they're trying to make everything right
for all the henna release does and they
could be called pas not to worry so we
have to go back to the the board again
and actually a APA has been very very
helpful with the state legislative folks
and they've been sending I think it's
about the third or fourth time that
they've sent information to the Puerto
Rican legislators legislators Luis Ramos
would tilia Ramos and myself none of
them relay neural ish actually have gone
down to the legislature and spoken to
folks now the interesting thing is as as
Justine pointed out this is like they're
they're fun and many of the positions
are legislators and that is an
interesting thing I just found out with
this new bill I was doing some research
on the woman who wrote this bill or was
putting it forward she and my cousin had
written some things I have to call my
cousin and find out what is the real
scoop but an older cousin when I went
down maybe three or four years ago said
physician assistants over my dead body
so it's the turf issues it's the under
Smith's understanding of what a
physician assistant is and they still
think that the Henry listas and the PAS
will be a problem although the people
that know and we've actually been
advertising in the opie tallies the
journal for especially the surgeons
surgeons that come to this
country to get residency they say what
do you mean we can't bring our pas down
with us because how can I harvest veins
I mean I can use a cardiothoracic
surgeon because they don't want to do it
so I'm going to stay in the states and
that's the brain drain so we're working
on the surgeons we're working on of
course the surgical pas keep coming to
us we we actually have a booth every
year and they keep saying well okay put
me on the list and will all work with
everybody but until there's more of an
understanding in on the island what
physician assistants are and do it won't
go forward but there's just little
pockets the the nephrologists want us to
do you know some of the work with the
you know dialysis thank you very much
i'm having more than a moment anyway so
that kind of stuff that the dialysis
works you know i mean if we could if we
can show that we will be cost-effective
and especially with the new health care
reforms that's I think where it's at but
and I've been working very closely with
in cat and the folks for health care
reform to actually make sure that we're
Rico was involved because at first
things weren't going to be yeah but it
did go through so anyway thank you for
the moment thank you so much for the
opportunity really appreciate